jeremy what what is this place oh you'll
be fighting these guys
what
[Music]
did you say i got a point scores 15
[Music]
i think we'll call it a day there lads
let's hit the showers yeah everyone see
you there
all right tom how are you feeling where
are we firstly
why have you got me off at 7am we're
here to do cushy wrestling
okay what's that no i thought it was
self-explanatory
kushti is an ancient martial art and
form of mud wrestling that dates back to
the 5th century bc
but back then they didn't call it mud
wrestling they just called it wrestling
it's as spiritual as it is physical and
any man who steps on the hallowed arena
is considered equal
except for toms he's a real piece of
work get your kill off mate oh god
i'll keep these on i didn't realize
this morning good way just a warm up
wait
no no it's a good shot good shot oh my
god
oh my god this is just stretching time
how much
there we go
he's gone drive through
here we go again come on
i can try this time just try it out
oh
come on
[Music]
so what jeremy had essentially done is
pay for me to get beaten up
worth every single penny however i was
told there was going to be another
match in half an hour so i decided it
was time to learn the rules i'll get him
on the rematch
a few moves what you do is you let him
think you're really bad
ah okay okay
i did a year of judo when i was seven
jeremy i thought i'd be better at this
you did that in judo uh no i did not
remember wiggling your hips look at him
start look at the starts
i can't my neck's been dislocated so is
he not allowed water
thinking about that rematch in 25
minutes okay swap me out swipe me out go
take it take a ticket
okay much better
i'll just i'll just stretch
right away after my intense precision
workout
it was time to find my next victim
you'll beat him beat him easy
unfortunately the kid wasn't in his
weight class and didn't want to hurt tom
so he went back to his first opponent
and gave him a rematch and i've seen
that guy like smoke five cigarettes then
sculla beer
time he's what you've been training for
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i thought a trendy montage fixed
everything turns out it doesn't
break that cut my toe pretty bad battle
wounds
what happens in the name of sport in the
name of good clean fun
it's not definitely not clean i think
we'll call it a day there lads let's hit
the showers yeah
everyone see you there